good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the major problems of the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is be truly fulfilled
over to you Tony Robbins Michael Gerber
the guy that wrote the e-myth you know
talks about why so many businesses young
businesses fail and one of these things
he says is most people are not really
entrepreneurs but they think that's what
they should be they think that's the
sexy thing that's the most attractive
thing that's the best answer and what I
say to you is you've got to separate the
vehicle from the outcome what is it this
going to truly fulfill you what is this
it's going to give you that
extraordinary life what's going to make
things magnificent on your terms not
somebody else's terms not your father
your mother your background what is that
really separate the vehicles there's
many ways to get to that vehicle but I'm
saying sometimes you got to reevaluate
what's going to really make you fulfill
what is your gift are you an artist are
you the talent can produce something no
one else produces as a skill or product
or a service or some impact are you
incredibly good management you really
know how to manage or lead people are
you an extraordinary entrepreneur that
has can take that gigantic gut load of
risk and can create division and attract
the talent that you need and the
managers and leaders you may have all
three abilities but which one really
fulfills you the most is going to be the
critical question because we tend to
want to do them all especially room like
this because you're all overachievers
right me too and you say well I can do
all these yes you can but what will it
do to your quality of life see again the
secrets going to be this what is an
extraordinary life on your terms today
getting clear about that at this stage
of life where you are where you want to
go I think it's really important to
build a life that you are running
towards instead of running away from
something that you don't like
let me explain I think people are
hardwired to avoid pain more than to go
out and seek pleasures when
tons of studies that have talked about
it people don't like pain we love
pleasure but we hate pain more than we
love pleasure and so how that often
translates into entrepreneurship is
people are acting not out of desire to
go off and do something big and
impactful but out of fear of pain and
trying to reduce the pain as much as
possible I've talked to so many
entrepreneurs I asked them why have you
start this business why is it so
important to you what do you what's the
reason behind it and whenever I get an
answer like I really hated my last job
you know my boss was really terrible or
I wanted I just wanted for you to I'm
gonna need to set my own hours if that's
why you're starting the business you're
going to fail because you're just
running away from a painful life and you
think entrepreneurship is the answer and
those are not the successful
entrepreneurs with successful
entrepreneurs are the ones who are going
to embrace the pain that comes along
with building the business and they want
the pleasure so much of going off and
building this really important thing
every time I make a video on YouTube
there's a lot of pain associated with it
there's comments that come in that may
not be great there's work that come out
and research it and make this happen for
you guys but we push through it because
I want to have an impact because I want
the work that I do to matter and so it I
would examine your reasons for wanting
to make that change in your life or in
your business ask yourself why am i
doing it if it's just to avoid something
and run away from my life that you don't
like oh it's not the answer you've got
to run towards something that you're in
love with and you want to build and you
want to see come to life stop running
away from your problems and go build
something amazing so the question date
today is I'm curious which one are you
did you set your business to run away
from problems you had in your life are
you trying to build something for the
future really curious to find out leave
it down in the comments below I also
want to give a quick shout out to Tim
Miller Tim thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word I
really really appreciate it man and I
hope you're enjoying the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events press
it spread to leukemia
[Music]
can we help us appreciate this early
experience these lean years these very
difficult years leading up to the
ultimate prize there is no prize out
there the only prize is this one and
what you feel and what you want to
accomplish and if you can as you start
out these what could be lean years or
could be fat ears I feel that I very
often watch a lot of young people sort
of meander around without any idea about
why they're doing what they're doing
I mean to want and to be ambitious and
to want to be successful is not enough
that's just desire to know what you want
to understand why you're doing it to
dedicate every breath in your body to
achieve if you feel you have something
to give if you feel that your particular
talent is worth developing is worth
caring for then there's nothing you
can't achieve how would you describe the
film it as a youtube user well you know
I think so filming it so filming is so
many YouTube producer talking to
different things I think fulfillment in
general as a filmmaker for me comes from
creating and that's why you know in 2010
they put the soundtrack on for the story
so I'll try to make it sound of style
too
I left like the mainstream meet the
mainstream sort of universe that I
wanted to create more so for me
fulfillment comes in creation and I
always say that like I'm a little bit of
a junkie and my drug is uploading
because if I haven't posted a movie in
like a month or month enough I get like
seriously depressed and the only thing
that like makes me happy is to get a new
movie out there that answers your
question right
I've never really been interested in
living a balanced life you know I don't
I think balanced people don't change the
world first of all I think balanced
people don't really follow a dream you
know this doesn't mean that you don't
have responsibilities it's like let's go
to those other parties question how can
you have a family well sure you can have
a family and have you know but balance
is kind of like I feel like balance is
like a made-up word it's like invented
by corporations you know to make their
employees think that they're happy you
know it's like you got this balance like
you could work at Microsoft you know are
something here in Seattle and there's
like 10 Microsoft people in the audience
right no disrespect to Microsoft Word
Microsoft Greg I went out of every five
bee buzz Rihanna or some I guess that's
right you know and it's like you know
you got you got this thing and maybe you
love your job if you love your job
that's great but I hear from a lot of
dissatisfied people and some of these
big companies and they write in or like
I'm reading your blog for my cubicle and
like you know I had this good job and
I've got my health insurance I've got
free yoga every Thursday but I'm not
really you know right I'm not really
fulfilled so for me I guess I'm much
more interesting that word fulfilled
like you know how can you live a
fulfilled life and you can live a
fulfilled life and still pay your bills
you lots of creative people do it lots
of unconventional people do it and it I
would say if anything it's actually much
more common now than it used to be you
know when I first started working online
you know 15 years ago I didn't know a
lot of other people who were doing that
you know my friends thought I was
selling drugs or something we were well
I was you know but for like online
gambling or whatever I like parents have
no idea how the internet works and stuff
but now it's it's much more common so I
don't really like the word balance
myself so what we'd like to do is we
want to replace the word like living a
balanced life is not the goal the goal
is living off a filled life